new at noon today a new bill signed by
governor steve sisolak earlier this
morning will provide more money to
thousands of struggling small businesses
assembly bill 106 will pump
an additional 50 million dollars into
the pandemic emergency technical support
grant program hector mejia live in the
southwest valley today with those
details hi hector
[Music]
hey there and the additional funding
brings the total
brings the total to more than 100
million in relief making it
the largest small business assistance
program in state history the task now
is getting it into the hands of business
owners like this one for example this
location
this is a small mexican family
restaurant pinchas tacos where some
employees have had to
pick up second jobs just to get by
assembly bill 106 will provide an
additional
50 million dollars to the pandemic
emergency technical support grant
program
the state assembly fast tracked it and
unanimously passed the bill earlier this
week
it'll provide ten thousand dollar grants
to an estimated nine thousand or so
small businesses or nonprofits that
qualify
and some are wondering if that's even
enough the vegas chamber says every cent
counts and that every
dollar could mean the difference between
closing or staying open
the mexican restaurant pinches tacos
here in the southwest says
morale has been low among fellow
business owners
of course it's a nice gesture the first
time uh we uh applied
we got the night uh haven't gotten the
reason yet
and i guess that's the frustrating part
like they're offering the money uh
but how can we get it and knowing we're
suffering it already being the toughest
business industry to be in and going
through that
and not getting the help i think we
deserve from the state and federal it's
not just the state
the nevada restaurant association
applauds the passage of assembly bill
106 in a written statement they told me
in part quote
with the recent increase in dining
capacity our operators are encouraged
however without full capacity they're
still facing serious difficulties
and the restaurant association estimates
that as many as 30 percent of
restaurants all across nevada
had to close their doors permanently by
the end of 2020
leading to a loss of about more than 16
thousand jobs
reporting live from the southwest dr
mejia 8 news now